as an entrepreneur when should I start
thinking about the hook model as early
as possible because the the idea here is
we well I'll tell you a personal story
so I've I've been at two companies and
one of my at the last startup that it
that I helped found one of the the
problems we constantly had was what do
we build right so we were big believers
in in the Lean Startup methodology of
build measure learn customer development
big believers and that still AM but we
always had this challenge of what do we
build next right this is where all the
blood sweat and tears and money all go
it's the building testing and learning
right measuring and learning that's easy
that's fun right it's the building
that's hard
so the question we constant constantly
had was you know what do we build next
do we build what the VCS say we should
build do we build with the loudest
customers say we should build do we
build what people who write into
customer support say we should build
what are we built and so what I what I
propose is that instead of just guessing
or you know taking a shot at our dot
voting even based on what the team
thinks we need some kind of framework
based on how people actually behave
because it turns out that just asking
people what they want is not a really
great measure because people can only
articulate certain things there's all
these in articulate able needs that
drive our behavior and people couldn't
tell you actually drive their behavior
so instead of just guessing
we need consumer psychology to help us
build the right things sooner we still
have to do build measure learn right
we're still gonna mess up or it's not
gonna build perfect products the first
time the idea is we can build the right
thing sooner by basing what we build on
the foundations of consumer psychology